bonsoir messieurs merci d'être avec nous
en direct sur ft france pour décrypter
donc
cette conférence internationale sur la
libye qui s'est tenue à paris
aujourd'hui quel bilan vous faites donc
à l'issue des déclarations que l'on a pu
entendre ahmed assaf d'abord
oui bonsoir
de son résultat concret de cette
conférence d'abord la volonté
internationale de régler le conflit
libyen par la diplomatie par la paix
c'est une première chose donc pas
question d'utiliser de manière forte de
la part des uns des autres
sassus première et deuxième chose là je
vois j'ai lu les 25 articles de des
conclusions de ce sommet ou de cette
confiance j'ai vu qu'il ya une une
pression qui est aujourd'hui confiance
plutôt donné par la communauté
internationale à cette commission mixte
militaire libyenne dit 5 + 5 pour
quelques pour qu'elles s'engagent
davantage avec la confiance aux
occidentaux et aussi de la russie pour
aller donc dégager le terrain et des
mercenaires et des milices et de toutes
les forces étrangères d'un côté unifie
de voir ces armes est allé d'un autre
côté donc là le chemin est encore tôt
mais là on voit très bien que cette
convention va jouer un rôle important
dans l'optique barre à michael
oui je crois que effectivement enfin il
faut il faut être optimiste mais garder
un optimisme prudent c'est à dire que
l'on voit bien dans les différentes
déclarations aussi bien dans la dette et
texte final que dans les différentes
déclarations de la part du président
emmanuel macron de la chancelière angela
merkel dut également du représentant un
état bien bien sûr du du chef du
gouvernement italien on voit bien que il
y à une prudence on voit bien qu'il ait
une recherche de consensus dans un
contexte dans lequel on sait que notre
la france et l'italie n'ont pas été
toujours à l'unisson concernant les
évolutions du dossier libyen mais je
crois que pourquoi est ce que je dis
optimisme prudent parce qu'il faut pas
oublier je veux dire la conférence de
presse finale était très révélatrice
finalement vous avez d'un côté le
président hahnemann fille et de l'autre
le premier istres débats dans un
contexte dans lequel on sait que les
deux hommes ne sont pas à l'unisson sur
beaucoup des perspectives liées à la
libye ça c'est d'un côté de l'autre
cette conférence et cette conférence de
presse mais en l'occurrence les
conclusions ont insisté sur deux axes
qui était prévu à la base à savoir que
d'un côté il faut organiser des
élections et commencer par les élections
présidentielles le 24 décembre et de
l'autre côté il faut que les mercenaires
se retire du pays et donc en ce sens
qu'elle mercenaires se retire des pays
je ne sais pas je n'ai pas
d'informations exactes mais j'ai
l'impression que ce sont 300 mercenaires
soit tchadien soudanais qui vont être
retirés mais cela laisse ouverts quand
même des questions de sécurité encore
dans le contexte est bien donc arrivées
des courses je crois qu'on est devant
effectivement une volonté je reçois je
rejoins ahmad youssef sur ce plan là
mais dans le même temps le chemin reste
long effectivement et on n'a même pas de
certitude sur le lendemain des élections
le lendemain du 24 décembre on l'a
entendu le chef de la diplomatie russe
sergueï lavrov évoqué le texte adopté
justement pour soutenir le processus
électoral qui doit normalement sortira
le pays du chaos dans lequel il est
plongé depuis la chute du guide libyen
mouammar al kadhafi
ahmed youssef est ce que vous êtes
confiant optimiste pour la suite pour la
tenue justement d'élections crédibles et
transparentes l'élection présidentielle
qui est prévue fin décembre
disons combat mais je suis optimiste
mais
peut-être la petite nuance entre lui et
moi c'est que je vois je vois le verre à
moitié plein écoutez
je vois qu'il ya une forme
internationale assez louable qui a été
fait à paris je vois qu il y avait là
vice-présidente américain je vois que la
russie l'un vous voir vous voulez faire
un effort là les dalots sens
l'écrivain que je suis dans le sens où
l'histoire pour sauver ce pays parce que
vous savez si on rate pas ce rendez vous
du 24 décembre le prix que les libyens
vont payer la région va piller la
communauté de la méditerranée d'appuyer
va être excessivement cher donc tout le
monde intérêts malgré les divergences a
intérêt à ce que ces élections aient
lieu et que ce que même s'il résultat à
l'arrivée ne sont pas tout à fait au
rendez vous de tout le monde à la
hauteur des espérances des explorations
de tout le monde mais il faut que ces
lieux je crois c'est là là on voit
qu'aujourd'hui à paris il y avait une
volonté assez
prononcé pour le coup ces élections
parce qu'il avait quelques doutes je
pense que
d'accord avec moi il avait jusqu'à une
semaine quand quelques doutes sur la
tenue de ces élections là aujourd'hui on
voit que ces élections et ils vont bien
avoir lieu parce que le filon le prix va
être très cher surtout de la part des
libyens vous êtes d'accord barah mikaïl
vous êtes confiant bosser ces élections
elles vont avoir enfin lieu
je suis d'accord moi car mon dieu c'est
pour le fait qu'effectivement j'ai
peut-être tendance à voir le verre à
moitié vide et non pas à moitié plein
mais pourquoi ça cela répond une raison
c'est à dire que notamment nous donne
aux danses activa consulting dans les
différentes évaluations que l'on est en
train de faire on s'attend à quelques 18
à 20% de participation de la part des
libyens aux élections sonne qui ne
garantirait pas une légitimité celui-là
cela se confirme ça c'est d'un côté de
l'autre on a une fragmentation
institutionnels effective il est vrai
qu'on a une détermination notamment de
la part de khalifa haftar longueur de
l'est de participer à ces élections mais
imaginons que il n'est pas qu'ils
n'aboutissent pas à une un résultat
politique et à un pouvoir en fait tout
une prise de pouvoir qui correspondent à
ces ambitions là je crois
qu'effectivement les spoilers dll et on
va dire ce qui est qui qui qui
parasitent un peu le processus
d'évolution de l'évolution politique en
libye pour y reprendre le dessus
ajoutons une chose le premier ministre b
bat normalement devrait ne devrait pas
se présenter à ces élections mais il se
dit de plus en plus qu'effectivement il
pourrait participer à ces élections dans
un contexte de flou juridique de flou
constitutionnel donc sur cette base là
est ce que ces élections auront lieu je
crois que oui s'est engagé le président
macro l'imam annoncé que au moins les
présidentielles auront lieu le 24
décembre mais les élections législatives
devaient avoir lieu le 24 décembre
également on ne sait pas si l on
moulures en janvier au plus tard et donc
dans ce contexte là je crois que se
convainc de saab en coin ou risque
d'entrer à partir du 25 décembre si les
présidentielles ou lui le 24 décembre
c'est la question du gouvernement actuel
parce que le gouvernement était prévue
pour durer de manière intérimaire
jusqu'à l'organisation d'élections et
donc ce flou juridique et cette absence
d'accord sur le plan libyen me rend
plutôt circonspect et plutôt prudente
quant à la possible évolution des choses
et cela pose aussi la question de la
sécurisation du futur scrutin à venir
tout à l'heure vous évoquez la présence
des mercenaires deux ans en libye c'est
une question qui a été évoquée par un
emmanuel macron qui a demandé justement
le départ de ces mercenaires annoncé le
départ de 300 d'entre eux probablement
détient dans le cadre d'un programme ddr
désarmement démobilisation réinsertion
justement ahmed youssef sur la présence
de ces mercenaires donc des mercenaires
tchadiens des mercenaires
soudanais turcs russes également qu'est
ce que l'on peut dire sur leur rôle et
l'impact qu'ils ont sur la situation
actuelle en libye
où ces mercenaires
tout dépendra des puissances régionales
parce que chacune de ses milices et ses
liens avec une mousse un hollow c'est au
même au delà
je pense bien sûr aux turcs au
magnat russe où je pense aussi à
diminuer africaines notamment du tchad
etc si si la communauté internationale
les puissances régionales à s'entendre
entre elles pour pour faire sortir ces
mercenaires sans problème d'ici le 24
déjà
mais pour quoi
que il ya uniquement on a annoncé la
sortie 3 1
personnel c'est parce qu'on savait que
la pression allait arriver et alan est
important donc les libyens ont pris le
devant un et que ça de la commission
militaire 7 5 a pris sa décision
courageuse d'ailleurs d'aller et décider
de la sortie ou l'évacuation de 300
personnes maintenant pour je finis la ce
que pour les milices il va falloir que
les puissances régionales
jouent un rôle positif je pense à mon
pays je pense à l'egypte c'est très
important parce que c'est le quinté
reçoit souvent la position militaire et
que si omar sy si on arrive à d'abord un
rang de l'élite bien prendre de la
confiance aux libyens eux mêmes je pense
que le reste pourrait être moins
difficile je veux pas dire facile mais
moins difficile qu'avant donc il n'ya
pas d'un possible dans l'histoire des
milices il va falloir que les puissances
grandes et régionales s'entendent et
après tout sera napoléon disait il faut
il faut aller c'est peu mais au delà on
ne commence pas des petites choses et on
pense à des choses un peu plus grande en
tout cas s'agissant de la question
présence de ces milices
en libye emmanuel macron a demandé donc
le retrait de mercenaires turcs et
russes de la libye on a le sentiment
balle nickel vous allez vous dire que
emmanuel macron il l'a quand même
pris comme prétexte cette conférence
internationale sur la libye pour régler
certains certains comptes on sait que la
russie en tout cas se défend de tout
lien avec wagner par exemple elle c'est
vrai promis une coopération militaire
par exemple avec le mali comme l'a
précisé le chef de la diplomatie russe
mais ce que ça donne quand même le
sentiment qu emmanuel macron ils règlent
des comptes dans le cadre d'une
conférence internationale sur la libye
qui est consacrée justement à la
promotion de ces futures élections
qu'est ce que vous en pensez
jerry manuel ou les très près clairement
en campagne pour les présidentielles
donc se la joue bien sûr sur une partie
du positionnement de la politique
française après dans le même temps ce
n'est pas et ce n'est pas si nouveau de
la part d' emmanuel macron je veux dire
si on regarde le long de son quasi
quinquennat maintenant il a quand même
pris pas mal de dispositions qui ont
montré qu'ils voulaient pousser l'agenda
français parfois je dirais je vous dirai
aux dépens de certains de ses
partenaires européens j'ai notamment en
tête ces différentes déclarations
notamment ses déclarations il ya deux
ans à marseille si mes souvenirs sont
bons sur les relations euro
méditerranéennes
donc il y revient sur cet agenda comme
ça après il faut pas oublier non plus
que quelque part paris cherche à faire
aussi bien que berlin c'est à dire que
merkel est sur le départ les deux faits
conférence de berlin on procédait à des
avancées paris cherche à rebondir sur
ses avancées en même temps à dire ben
nous on est aussi en train d'entraîner
les perspectives vers des horizons qui
peuvent marcher qui sont positifs ce
n'est pas nouveau non plus mac on l'a
essayé à plusieurs reprises et là ils
essayent de faire une place à la
diplomatie française mais sur le fond du
fond concernant cette insistance sur les
aides sur la question des mercenaires
n'oublions pas que malgré que parmi les
milices que l'on retrouve en libye il y
à des milices libyenne également je vais
dire qu il n'y a pas d' armée forte il
ya des armées en concurrence une armée
qui plus forte d'un côté que de l'autre
mais dans le même temps si on a des
mercenaires étrangers qui se retrouvent
sur le terrain en libye c'est également
parce qu'il ya une situation de vide qui
prévaut en libye depuis maintenant
depuis au moins dix ans parce que des
astros kadhafi on ne peut pas dire qu'il
y avait une armée très forte non plus
qui qui qui présidait au pays donc dans
ce contexte là bien sûr la france
cherche à faire la différence la france
cherche aussi à montrer que finalement
il ya eu peut-être des désaccords
profonds désaccords avec l'italie dans
le passé mais que là elle a une attitude
plus responsable mais il faut encore oui
je crois que ceux qui manquent à la
france c'est quand même le poids sur le
terrain comme tel à la france tout comme
aux autres pays d'ailleurs ce n'est pas
la seule l'allemagne l'italie même chose
mais non dans ce contexte là je dirais
ne mettons pas entièrement de côté le
fait qu'on est vraiment dans beaucoup de
mal heureusement on est quand même dans
beaucoup de communication et que le fond
de la chose c'est qu'effectivement le 24
décembre paraît être un déterminant
important mais ma crainte devant cette
échéance électorale c'est que finalement
les déçus du scrutin et les déçus des
élections cherche plutôt à faire des
routes et la machine libyenne une fois
encore
vous permettez d'uriage
la question des élections
présidentielles françaises effectivement
emmanuel macron est donc là il est
presque au terme de son mandat et qu'en
france un pays que je connais très bien
qu'en tant les présidents fin ce qui
tient le pouvoir
rapidement
la gloire de président en france elle
est allée elle passe par la porte de la
politique étrangère la diplomatie on a
vu ça avec le général de gaulle pour la
vie s'est arrêtée de terrain on a vu ça
avec tout le monde et après macro et lui
c'est
l'image de la france dans le monde
c'était presque une obsession française
et doux sur l'engagement sur le dossier
libyen là je rejoins plus que ce qu'a
dit bara mais je rajoute seulement très
rapidement parce que la france elle est
déjà présent dans l'église il ya déjà
des militaires français des experts et à
des forces et bien il ya des services on
le sait très bien et comme le dossier
intéresse beaucoup d'argent pour des
gens bien des gens géopolitique mais
aussi parce que et à lugano mais si
toutes questions merci beaucoup à vous
ahmed youssef journaliste écrivain et
universitaire à égyptien spécialiste du
monde arabe merci a également avoué bara
à michael directeur de stratégie à
consulting professeur à l'université
saint louis à 2 madrid